welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down wood e and Ponder the
question what if what if what if what if
the eighth episode of season 2 is now
out and there's a lot to unpack from it
the episode season alternate version of
the timeline set in 16002 that we
discover is being racked by world ending
Stakes there's a lot to talk about and
the basis for this Earth actually has
some roots in the comic
can't talk about them without giving a
spoiler though so if you don't want to
know then turn off now if you enjoy the
video please click the thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day without the way a
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into 1602 strange what are you
doing here hope Peg I got a story to
tell you okay so back in 2003 Neil
gaming and Andy Cuba dropped the 1602
storyline which took place over eight
issues this saw strange weather patterns
happening across the planet which made
many believe that the apocalypse had
started gaan said he always saw the
Marvel universe as magic and had really
wanted to explore this time period like
the episode there were Rifts in time and
it turned out that Steve Rogers had been
sent back which had caused the issues
things got tied up with Steve going back
but several sequel Comics spun out from
this this included one in which a spider
landed on Peter Parker's hand which was
set off because of the energies from the
rift which contaminated the spider there
some really cool callbacks of the comics
they doing this as well and medieval
universes in general have also appeared
in other stories during Jonathan
Hickman's fantastic forun we watched his
redard built a bridge to look into other
worlds this allowed him to see into
other realities in order to try and
solve the problems of his own for
example something like Civil War went
down worse than me missing the first
four episodes of what if and Reed wanted
to see if there had been a world that
fixed it thus he stared into the
Multiverse and searched for realities
that would help his here he saw a
medieval one that had solved their Civil
War problem and we got to spend about an
issue roughly in that setting so yeah A
lot's going on and we actually pick up
with Peggy sort of already settled into
this universe when we last left her
she'd just been pulled into it but here
she's been there for a while
investigating the issues in the end it's
another instance where Steve and Peggy
can't be together because reality is
tearing itself apart turns out that when
Steve was fighting Thanos that he struck
the time Stone which ended up shattering
it this is caused the early 21st century
in the 1600s to become compressed
explaining why the heroes with Steve are
also back in this time everything up to
Infinity war was exactly the same so
these figures wouldn't have been born
back in the past that they just all got
pulled into it this is what's caused the
issues and we begin with Loki reciting
Hamlet on stage at the globe theat this
is where a lot of early Shakespearean
Works debuted at and ly mentions his
friend will later on will has written a
new play and it's about this character
called Iago that's William Shakespeare
obviously and in the upper section we
catch saw his sister Hela Nick Fury and
happy Hogan Hogan ends up going happy
Hulk Hogan later on and brother the puns
are still A1 now Loki sucked up into the
sky where he's pulled down by Peggy but
sadly the rift still ends up doing its
damage pulling hel up this now puts Thor
in charge who takes his scepter also I
don't know why hel is here cuz she was
dead at this point by Infinity War but
we'll just glance over that and pretend
it's all fine if you know comments below
but the septer obviously resembles the
one that ly carried an Avengers
however we can see it's got the time
Stone instead of the Mind One and this
is because it's all tied in with lots of
timey wiy wibbly wobbly stuff with the
time Stone coming back too during Secret
Wars they try to use the Infinity Stones
to stop an incursion but this shattered
them all except for the time Stone this
is somewhat sentience and th a travel
through time in order to survive now
these storms are growing stronger and
stronger and those peggies deemed as
being a cursed that's causing them to
get worse but I'm not a rapper I also
love how when you see happy come in you
can see him go purple for a second
because man's just about to Hulk out him
doing this was of course set up in the
Die Hard episode with his purple Hulk
probably using the eggplant Emoji with
even more accuracy now the reason that I
brought up the Civil War thing before is
that after the title sequence we get a
sort of sovian Accord split in both of
the teams however thorus replaced Tony
with Tony now being on the side of the
rebels Peggy like cap is on the run and
we discover that wand reached out into a
neighboring Universe in order to save
her own I do wonder if the reason things
are actually getting worse is because of
the way that incursions work in the MCU
were then worsening due to Peggy's
arrival in the movie universe and
incursion happens because someone's in
an alternate reality for way too long
this pulls the together and I wonder if
Peggy being here is what's causing the
added issues that's a f but yeah in
those reality ending days it's
definitely worth discussing hey guess
what very excited to talk about today's
sponsors ag1 we've been using them for
months now I feel a hell of a lot better
on myself and yeah I'm very excited to
work with this brand and tell you about
all the benefits a1's the daily Health
habit that's filled with vitamins
minerals Whole Food sourced ingredients
and probiotics since having the kids and
send them to Nursery they've been
bringing back lots of diseases so I've
been looking for ways to boost my immune
system which is where ag1 come in it's a
simple supplement and with just one
scoop you get 75 vitamins and minerals
that replenish your daily nutrients and
leave you feeling better personally I
was also always drinking coffee all the
time like three cup a day at least but
this just gives me the energy that I
need throughout the day ag1 gives a
comprehensive nutrition supplement that
provides nutrients for your body brain
and good health and you're welcome kit
you'll get an ag1 pouch a refillable
canister AG vitamin D12 and K2 you'll
also get the ag1 travel pack shake a
bottle and a scoop as well it's very
simple just one scoop in give it a shake
and it also has a lovely vanilla R
pineapple flavor so it tastes great as
well I'm just so used to doing it now
it's become a daily Health habit but I
look forward to how it makes me feel cuz
it just starts off the day on the right
foot just go to the link in the
description click that and you're going
to get a year free supply of vitamin D3
and K2 plus five ag1 travel pouches with
your first purchase huge thank you to
ag1 for sponsoring this video just try
them out yeah because it's going to make
you feel more energized you'll feel
better on your body and yeah I
definitely recommend that you check them
out in the description thank you now we
discover that this universe is dying and
Peggy shows her perceptions improveed by
hearing the Watcher in the comics he
would normally appear when there was a
seminal event about to go down but I
think her meeting him before means she
can pick him up even she's a bit annoyed
by his narration but she refuses to go
back to her world we see Nick going
through battle strategies and a sword
and shield it works in this universe the
Nick Fury brings up nebula's Observatory
and the aisle of ego which he you get
them also I like how ego is an Ireland
oras he's a planet in the main Universe
because he just likes to be off doing
his own thing wanted talks about the
future person which has caused the Rifts
and a makes sense it's Steve cuz he's
the man out of time over hearing this we
see his fur's playing both sides as per
usual and he instructs Peggy to take it
as a new Mission cutting across to the
barn we see this universe is Tony Stark
and can catch a mark one armor type mask
on the side later on we see the mark one
being used on Bruce Banner with him
being a play on The Man in the Iron Mask
Tony and Peggy examine the skull which
came close in contact to the tear and
thus has its minerals he also asks her
for some of her words with her saying
flux capacitor which I I quite like this
obviously comes from Back to the Future
and bit of spam we've got a big
breakdown on the movie on the channel
right now now koki who talks about
Shakespeare writing a play about EO who
was a character that popped up in aell
the way he talks about him later it's
clear that Loki's playing him but guys
you missed out on a bloody deep cut
surprised that he didn't say CIO as zatu
Heston played when Kenneth Brer saw him
for the first time Kenneth Brer Direct
directed the first th and as I've been
saying it's all connected all connected
shirts available now below the video
help support the channel anyway his
Carriage is rans sacked by Rogers Hood
and his band of merry men Rogers Hood
you don't need me to go by the Robin
Hood connections said do you make come
on come on man PR promise the wife I'd
have the week off for Christmas in New
Year no no all right so so Robin Hood
was a British fog tale that originated
in Nottingham about a kindhearted Thief
who stole from the rich and gave to the
poor here is band of Merry men's made up
of Ant-Man and the Winter Soldier with
buck even having a black and silver
metal arm like how he did around
Infinity War Scott's got his belt and we
can also see that cap still has the star
in the middle of his chest believing
he's seen a go Steve says as margara
passed away many moons ago and in the
initial reality came from she of course
died during Civil War but had her
passing away around the start of the
film and as endgame hasn't happened yet
he hasn't got to go back the pair are
still destined to be together there and
we see as they have a talk in a bar this
is the location that the pair of often
sat and got closer to each other with
Peggy not really wanting to discuss her
Steve no I I don't think I will which is
beautifully polling From This Moment
no no I don't think I will however it's
broken up by the arrival of the yellow
jackets which builds off the back of
ant-man's first major foe these
assassins Force Scott to shrink too with
him riding on the back of Anthony who
comes from that first film cap shield in
this also somewhat hint to there being
ties to Infinity War as it's a similar
shape to how it appeared in that man's
also rocking the beard and the slick
back look too so we can date him as
coming from the infinity war time period
now Bucky messes up and makes happy mad
which is that is that why they did did
the whole thing to do a happy and mad
pun I can't I can't be the judge of that
it would be like the pot calling the
kettle black widow if I made fun of that
um but yeah I can't be mad at the bad
pun and I feel that's why they did it
anyway the destroyer from Thor is
brought in with them busting out the ey
lasers that we saw in that Atman ends up
turning this on its own men and Peggy
has to drop in in order to block the
blast this gives a similar shot to the
famous one from Civil War that not only
appeared in the movie but also in the
comics cut a Red Skull who's now an
executioner and we see his peggies put
up in a tower this is similar to the
Tower of London which was useless a way
to hold enemies of the realm and even
Queens themselves namely Queen Elizabeth
and way the Watcher shows up to speak
with Peggy with him constantly saying
what if what if the world doesn't
magically correct itself what if it's
the final straw that destroys this
universe what if when the universe
resets you're trapped here forever
busting free we get a great one shot of
Peggy rushing through the corridor
taking down the knights coming across
the monster in the Iron Mask he actually
prefers how peaceful it is imprisoned
this is something Hulk goes to a lot of
times in the comics and after World War
Hulk he was kept underground this was a
place Bruce preferred to be as it meant
that the Beast couldn't be Unleashed
however after Peggy gets to self fired
upon Hulk busts free and we see him
recovering some of how he did during Age
of Ultron back at Tony's lab we see a
nice little historical nod with some
bat-like wings hanging up on the wall
he's a base in the ones by Leonard daini
which later went on to inspire Bill
finger and Bob Kane Bob Kane's Batman
Google Bill finger and Bob Kane Batman
if you want to learn more anyway Steve
the band arrived with him returning the
shield and they decid to do a heist on
the RO Court a te opens across the
ceiling resembling the ones on our way
home and after Hulk busts in it all goes
down happy and Steve go head to-head
with happy saying taste my steel this
might be a reach but I actually think
it's a reference to Scott Pilgrim he my
steel we eventually get a happy versus
Hulk Showdown to see who the strongest
Avenger is and you might notice that
this Hulk has the beard whereas the one
in the Die Hard episode didn't finally
making it to Thor we sees he pulls out a
vibranium sword which we Lear was gifted
by the prince of wakanda oh Father give
me strength this is something Thor has
uted throughout the Saga in times in
need All fathers give me strength capos
ends up taking down Red Skull and leads
to wonder rebelling and holding Thor in
place like Civil War she ends up
switching sides and this allows them to
put the stone in the machine this
provides Peggy with a gauntlet and it
allows her to unleash time energy this
stops the rip from tearing the world
apart and it finally reveals that Steve
is the Forerunner remembering the fight
with Thanos we get a flash of the end of
infinity war and see how it all went
down Peggy's desperate to get a happy
ending but alas this isn't the case and
he has to return home he says that he's
sure they're out there somewhere they do
and as we know there is a reality in
which they get to be together now all
the heroes are sent back to their time
with Peggy still remaining in the time
period as she wasn't with them she
hasn't been sent back and we get a tease
of what's to come in the finale with
Supreme strange rocking up and I'm
guessing that like the first season of
what if we'll see these story lines
coming together with all the characters
making an appearance for that strange of
course showed up in the kahori episode
and thus I think both she and Peggy at
the very least are going to cross paths
personally I think it's going to be a
big Ensemble and I can't wait to see
what goes down in it anyway that wraps
up the entry and thanks again for
joining me I do feel bad for missing
those first four but yeah ju just
couldn't do it with the team's time off
and wanting some time with the kids
apologies for that but yeah thank you
for all your support anyway and huge
thank you if you dropped a like on the
video you want to support the channel as
a member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button and as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos every week you want something
else to watch we've got a what if videos
on screen right now the ones we did uh
so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
sing through the video I've been your
host Paul I'll see you next time take
care
peace oh